all right let's have a look at this old
familiar friend Ryan you're good right
this is Pythagoras theorem we love
Pythagoras's theorem because we're good
at Pythagoras's theorem with okay now
what I want to point out to you is just
have a look at what I've written as
these equations that you recognize as
Pythagoras's theorem quick question
which one is Pythagoras theorem okay now
in some ways in some ways it's a trick
question
because clearly I got to this line from
this line do you say what did I do to
both sides to get for me yeah I
subtracted B squared from both sides
right and then I did a bit of a switch
okay so they're the same object usually
we state Pythagoras theorem in this way
okay Agni are you good
great however we use this one sometimes
I'm going to answer your question when
would we use the first one and when
would we use the second because they're
slightly different arena
okay just as you can catch that right
even though you really can find anything
you need from either of those we tend to
use the top one when we're after the
hypotenuse II and we tend to use this
one when we're after a shorter leg the
question is how did you know how did you
recognize see here's the hypotenuse over
here it's a it's the subject of the
equation right it's the subject the
subject is the thing you're after like
when you see this what is the thing
you're trying to find you're trying to
find the area of a circle you know I
mean you can find the radius if you know
the other thing but this is what you're
after that's why you put it front and
center
same deal over here okay now yesterday
when we wrote this sine rule I actually
wrote it in two ways do you remember
what they were I wrote one like this and
then I wrote another one just like it
but upside down like so now just like up
here both of these guys are the same
rule they're both the same rule but
which one you use depends on what you're
after
okay have a look at this guy what looks
like it's closest to being the subject
what's closest you actually did this a
lot yesterday it's how I'm gonna be
little a this guy here because quite
easy to multiply both sides by sine
whatever and then you have a little a as
the subject okay what about this guy
down here what's the subject it's gonna
be this guy this is what turns up being
easiest okay
now you really can use either just like
you cannot use either form for
Pythagoras's theorem but if you're
trying to find angles like we're about
to do today then what I like you do is
write it like this
that gets the angle in a nice convenient
spot okay so let's have a go at 2a
can you draw the diagram for two now
what are we going to use these colors
for when you're using the sine rule
you're thinking about the positions of
angles and sides in relation to each
other what you need is an angle that's
the one you're trying to find in this
case what's a chord
what's this night it's alpha X I agree
and you want to compare it to the side
that's opposite which in this case is 9
over there okay in the same way I want
to think about the other angle that I
know and the side that's opposite which
in this case is 11 okay I highly
encourage you to draw it like this so
you can identify which one is which and
that's why having two colors is handy
okay now that I know what's what I'm
going to state the sign rule with the
information from this question so I'm
gonna have sine alpha on 9 there's an
angle and it's opposite side
what will the right-hand side look like
okay sign because they forget it's the
side rule sine of 59 degrees divided by
11 okay so from here I just have to
multiply both sides by 9 and then get my
calculator ready you're going to get an
answer for this from your calculator I'm
going to encourage you to put in 1959 on
11 and you're going to get some decimal
points aren't lots of them actually can
you write them down for me maybe give me
like four or five give me more detail
than you need has anyone got it already
yep what do you got yeah three sorry dot
dot dot okay so this is enough for me to
say look I've got the actual number when
I'm the marker and I have a look if I
see this I know you've done in your
calculator whereas like this you could
have just guessed that at random okay
that you can't guess it really fits
exactly right the next step is I
actually don't want sine of alpha
I want alpha so what will I do yeah
shift sign so you're going to get this
on your calculator display dot dot which
is equal to saying your 40 dot dot dot
now at this point look at the question
look at the question does it ask for
approximation of any kind near zero
point one okay so in this case that'll
be forty four point five degrees
yeah 0.128 one decimal place yeah that's
alpha okay quick sense check forty-four
forty four point five degrees does that
look about right yeah look a smaller
angle angle opposite a smaller side
thumbs up okay